That ends the lesson on PCA.
It's a very general method.
People use principle
components all the time.
And the face recognition method is
just what we use to introduce it.
Although I will say, it's become very
well known because, not just because how
well it worked and caught,
sort of caught people by surprise, but
just it had this very
clean interpretation.
In fact, now people, you'll hear,
instead of eiganfaces,
you'll hear about eigangaits.
Right?
So you,
you take measurements of people walking,
you try to find a principle component
analysis, project them down and do it.
There are eigan body shapes,
which is terrifying to think about, but
basically the idea of, I've, you know,
people vary in different shapes, and
I should be able to take a small
number of variations and
say I can fit you by just
a small number of control knobs.
If you're doing computer graphics
animation, and you want to be able to
control the different shapes of
people to build different characters,
you want to be able to just turn
a small number of knobs and
have people change their overall build,
their height, and things like that.
And you can use this,
principal component analysis, or
more sophisticated versions of it,
to do that.
The method that I've shown you
here also is a linear method.
Right?
All these things are orthogonal.
And I could compute the coefficients
by just taking the dot products.
And that's a nice property to have,
it makes things easy to do, but
it's also a liability.
If I have a, just say,
a three-dimensional space,
suppose I have points that actually
just lie along a curve, okay?
So they are all on a single curve,
which means if you just told
me the value along that curve,
that would represent the point
completely, assuming I knew the curve.
But it's not a line, it's a curve,
okay, so it, it bends.
So there are non-linear methods of doing
principal component analysis that allow
you to capture, sort of non-linear,
lower-dimensional manifolds.
We won't talk about it here, but,
in fact there's one's called
non-linear kernel PCA.
But for now, all you need to know
about is what we talked about here,
linear orthogonal decomposition
of principle components.